we turn to the phone lines here at top
of hour number three here the day after
that tom brady announces his retirement
after 22 years in the league the tampa
bay times columnist and reporter who's
been covering the bucks forever today
rick stroud is back here on the rich
eisen show how you doing
hey rich i'm doing well how are you i'm
doing fine so
walk me through uh the retirement
announcement process uh with all of that
that happened with brady best you can
tell the timeline of that portion
of this
well it was crazy because and and he
doesn't get enough credit but really
jason luck and fora um you know last
friday night
sort of broke the news that brady's
retirement was imminent that it would
happen you know sometime after the
championship game and then some 20 hours
went by i mean we were contacting the
bucks and they're like no no no haven't
heard from them don't know what's going
on there don't don't know if i put much
credence in that
uh and then like i said the next
afternoon late afternoon um as i've said
before rich when you hear adam schefter
come on
you know espn and go according to my
sources tom brady
very good
at that point
at that point you know okay all right
now then who has better better sources
right
uh with tom brady than him and jeff
darlington
um and then there was this you know
sort of a almost uh when i when i was
talking to bruce when i was talking to
jason i mean they felt
not that it couldn't happen but just
that that again
you know they were heard of i think
about the fact that all this was coming
out before they had talked to tom about
it and
you know so i don't know i think they
probably thought it was inevitable
but it wasn't until and then tom goes on
you know monday night on the let's go
podcast with jim gray i don't know what
that was uh him saying that he still was
you know trying undecided and you know
would make an announcement when he when
he had decided
and then you know 9 30 in the morning
937 whatever was
you know you have this very lengthy you
know uh five or six part statement that
clearly he didn't craft that morning so
it was a very clumsily uh you know un
brady like sort of rollout of his
retirement
um
again i i think the bucks were sort of
you know prepared for it in a sense but
and i think you know he didn't really
call jason light until
really monday night i guess after the
jim gray podcast and told him that this
was coming
on tuesday morning so it's just
you know just a weird deal and i have my
suspicions i mean i i i suspect that you
know we haven't seen the last episode of
man in the arena as the man leaves the
arena um you know espn plus has part of
that and and at some point
you know i expect to see him sit down
and say you know hey daddy has a new
team and i'm staying with you guys you
know and
um we'll see how that all plays off in
in the cinema but
uh it just you know it was just a weird
weird weekend for sure because you got
to watch his career funeral before he
actually said he was done yeah it was
and and then you know uh jason light in
the bucks said that brady called him up
and said i haven't decided anything yet
but you know then and then you hear from
some that uh there were indications this
was it
weeks before so what was the general
sense of things around the team did you
get any sense that brady was thinking of
retiring as he was playing out the rest
of this season rick
no you really didn't get that sense i
mean you know he's so focused on the day
on the task at hand you know i'll say
this about tom and i
i didn't get to really you know because
of the pandemic uh we didn't get to
spend a lot of the time you would have
in the locker room normally and get to
know him personally i obviously met him
at the hall of fame really we did zooms
the whole first year and then you know
met him at the hall of fame uh when
peyton manning went in had the only
one-on-one i think locally before the
start of the season but he's very
present
you know he's very he's very present
when he's
when he's talking to you and and he
stays that way throughout the season
but i got a believer it's just like he
said you know they asked him uh when he
came to tampa when did you know it was
over in new england he said well when i
knew i didn't have a contract for the
next year i went into the season
thinking that this was this was my last
year there i was pretty sure of it and i
think he probably felt that way you know
he he signed a two-year contract they
extended it for cap reasons the
possibility of him wanting to play until
he was 45 and he even told me in
september when he got up from that
interview he goes i hope we can do this
again i plan to be here many years
and i thought well that's good because
he'll be back you know next season if
that's what he's saying
um
but you know i i just think that he you
know the idea of having won a super bowl
already
look he goes out on top he's the the
league's leading passer with over 5 300
what 16 yards you know 43 touchdowns
mean if not for some really bad defense
at the end of the rams game maybe
they're playing next weekend in the
super bowl again so
um it was just time he had talked about
the pull from his family all during the
year you know it wasn't just june grace
podcast he had told us similar things um
you know about where he was in life and
where his kids were in life so i think
it's something that he he probably had
worked out in his mind if not him and
his wife worked out and and we were all
just kind of like thinking well maybe
this can go on but uh in reality too
many too many business things too rich
you see everything he does in the
expanded business portfolio that's going
to demand his time as well so
um disappointing but uh not surprising
rick stroud tampa bay times here on the
rich eisen show let's turn the page then
starting with
uh who's at
quarterback um is this going to be kyle
trask's job
to win um who would they be bringing in
are they going to just is it going to be
trask versus gabbard they're going to
draft walk me through
what they're thinking now that it's
official brady's not coming through the
door to play
i mean rich they're they're thinking is
andrew luck got any any chance of coming
out of retirement i mean really you know
i mean they will they will exhaust
everything um you know door number two
is where tom brady walked through one
time now there is no tom brady out there
for them unfortunately
um and and i think it's unrealistic to
think that you know
if aaron rodgers left green bay that
they would the packers would trade him
to tampa they didn't trade brett favre
here they traded him to the jets instead
um you know same is probably true with
russell wilson if in fact he were to
leave
you know do you do you go to to the
texans and how many draft picks would
you have to package and then hope that
desean watson isn't going to get
suspended you know um jimmy garoppolo is
an agreement with the 49ers um you know
do you think he's salvageable you know
he's a winner but he's been hurt he says
he wants to go to a winning team i mean
there's there's only so we all know the
names right we all know the prospects
and there's so many teams even in this
division except for maybe atlanta but
maybe also atlanta looking for
quarterbacks
um and any team that were to trade you
one would then be in that same market so
it's difficult you know when they went
through this before and they didn't know
if they could get tom clyde christensen
sat down and at that time there were
quarterbacks like philip rivers was out
there and of course he played one year
at the colts
teddy bridgewater was the guy they were
going to turn to next he wound up going
to carolina because they got brady and
then we saw him in denver
you just don't know like what what tier
of quarterback are you able to pry out
of another team but i think they'll look
for a veteran i think you know they
don't probably believe that trask is
quite ready they might like him more
than some of the guys in the draft this
year
but he had a redshirt season
you know and he didn't play at all he
was inactive every single game
excuse me and
you know i just think
they don't know what they have there
they do know they have a pretty veteran
team they can retain some free agents um
the south is wide open again so
um yeah it's it's really wide open and i
mean that they they will look everywhere
uh to try to find the best option well
and the question is is that if the
option does come down to
just deciding you know what we we
i guess thinking within the building is
it's trasks gig
is that something aryans wants to do
like what's the scoop with bruce's
future there do you think
yeah you know i've talked to bruce a
bunch um and i didn't know if it was
rhetoric because he didn't know tom's
fate or not um you know right now he's
he's trying to rest at home this
achilles thing was a nightmare for him
at the end of the year
he's trying to avoid surgery because
that's a whole nother
rehab situation he might ultimately
might need it
um but he told me you know with or
without brady he was going to come back
and coach and you know he'll be 70 in
october um you know he he gutted through
the year quite frankly like his team
playing hurt all season
but it looks like rich he's going to get
back byron leftwich it looks like he's
going to get back todd bowles that makes
life a lot easier for bruce arians it
really does
and you know they've got a good football
team they need a quarterback like like
so many other teams but you know seven
of their nine pro bowlers are still
under under contract and they'll get
some more of these free agents to come
back especially if bowls and or left
which are here they'll probably
franchise chris godwin if they can't
reach an agreement with him so it's
still it's still a pretty good team um
you know like i said but for a few plays
on defense and the injuries you know
with tristan worse really wiped them out
they got to get some offensive linemen
um you know brian jensen and alex capper
are free agents but they may get one of
those guys back so all is not dark and
gloomy it'll never be as bright and
shiny as it was with brady um but but
you know they they feel like they have a
pretty good football team and i think
bruce knows that and i think he wants to
coach again and i think he will
rick strout here uh on the rich eisen
show uh and just moments ago in
discussing bruce aaron's future you're
gonna again your your guesses and
hearing from him he's staying there and
the the helpful piece of that would be
to have both it said you said it looks
like he's going to have bowls
and byron left which back why
why
because teams aren't smart enough to
hire them because brian flores is right
um you know i i can't explain in any
other way i mean jacksonville
is dysfunctional at best no matter who
they hire right i mean
um and i think i suspect trent balckey
is somebody that a lot of coaches
probably don't want to work for or with
um and you know byron has gone in there
now twice
you know uh
it it's too easy right you got a guy who
has a history with the jaguars it was an
nfl how many nfl quarterbacks
that really played at that level draft
high draft picks calling plays
sat around with tom brady for a couple
years one of super bowls 42 years old
and you've got trevor lawrence sitting
there you don't want this guy to work
with him really you don't think he's
going to be a good head coach
i don't know i don't know who would be
better uh they have a lot of names of
talking to everybody but they haven't
pulled the trigger on anything so i know
byron is a candidate with new orleans
which is interesting
um
and i don't know where they're going to
go but you know yeah i mean todd bowles
was in it in minnesota he was in it with
the raiders
those two programs look like they're
going another way so you know both those
guys deserve to be head coaches for
bowls again for buying the first time i
don't know what this league is is
thinking you know with just mike tomlin
right now who had to win 15 straight
years to keep his gig
um it's a shame and you know there's
three african-american coordinators here
this organization i will say has had
three black head coaches and probably
the next one will be as well um i don't
understand why there's not diversity in
this league in coaching it just it's
it's it's frustrating
but it'll be to the bucks benefit if
those two guys are back and the thing
about leftwich too is he's hand he's
bruce aryan's is hand
picked
coach for play calling he was the one
who who took leftwich essentially
from from home for after he retired and
basically said i think you can do this
and and i've spoken to left witch about
this and what arians
saw in him and and and what he's proven
uh uh and and your point is perfectly
well taken
that i guess he you know he doesn't want
to work with trent balke that that that
he's still there right i mean everything
else checks every box it makes zero
sense
and to be fair i have not talked to
byron about bulky that's speculation on
my part but i but i but i do know that
the last three teams bulky has worked
for and two of the coaches he hired were
one and done okay um you know i think
here's what i think about byron and and
bulls too
these guys are smart guys uh you know
byron told me he said rick you know i've
been a quarterback in this league i've
made plenty of money i'm not one of
these coaches that say i got to be a
head coach by the time i'm this age or
that age he he just enjoys you know
helping guys play you're right he had to
be talked into coaching he was on the
golf course for five years and and he
got the bug and aryans knew how he saw
the game he sees the whole game you know
some coaches it's it's the run game some
coaches it's the passing game some of
them don't understand the complimentary
you know with the defense or special
teams byron sees the whole picture and
he's watched the game from under center
i mean that's a rare perspective there's
a lot of great you know play callers on
that sideline never stood behind the
center never looked down the barrel at a
guy you know in a you know zero blitz um
but but byron has and
so and now
and this is even bigger you know as much
as byron thotting knew or knew
he has a whole hell a lot better
perspective on playing the position with
two years of working with tom brady who
took this offense and and fit it to his
own skill set and did it a different way
sees the game a different way and so
he's benefited from that i don't know
why people won't hire him he's a great
people person he does not make excuses
i've been around long enough to know
he's going to be successful when he gets
his shot if it's with the right team but
i think these guys are smart i think
they realize it takes more you know than
just a quarterback prospect um and you
know the raw raw speech at the press
conference to win in this league and the
longer it goes you know these other
staffs are going to be filled out that's
the other thing this football team here
in tampa won because bruce harry could
get together a hell of a coaching staff
if you're if you're not hired a head
coach yet guess what all those other
staffs are starting to scatter and be
sucked up by these guys that have been
hired and it's going to put you behind
the eight ball last one for you then
rick is is what's your reporting on the
other aspect of the brian flores lawsuit
about the accusation of tanking that uh
stephen ross
offered a hundred thousand for every
loss of the 2019 season that obviously
didn't lose enough for what what's your
what's your reporting on that
if you have any
i don't have any reporting i will tell
you if you ask me you know it's kind of
like it's kind of like a few good men if
you ask me
if code reds go on around here on the
record i tell you no off the record i
tell you it's a valuable tool um there
have been teams
and i've covered one
and and i'm not really pointing fingers
i don't think it was the owners
necessarily but i mean i watched i would
say this
go back and watch the last game of the
season before jameis winston comes out
um and plays you know in his drafted
number one overall by the bucks the
bucks were going to be number one or
number two in the draft they were
playing new orleans drew brees is down
10 points they couldn't do that right
they're going to beat the new orleans
saints in the final game of the season
they're gonna get the number two pick
and tennessee's gonna have number one
and all of a sudden the bench is empty
and the starters come out
and
aaron rodgers gets hot and there's man
coverage everywhere and guess what
the bucks lost the game and after the
game we asked well why wasn't mike evans
in what well you know we'd be remiss
without seeing these young guys before
yeah
no i know we've heard that before like
what last game of the season stuff i
mean this is something i've never heard
i mean this is true if any of this is
true rich it talks about it's the
integrity of the game i mean what are we
watching wwe i mean like all of a sudden
you know you don't know which team is
trying to win and which one is trying to
lose and then you have financial ones
i've never heard of something like this
and apparently if it's been going on
they got a bigger problem than not
hiring enough
coaches in this league you know that
aren't white and and giving minorities
an opportunity and equal opportunity
that's
that to me is
you know beyond something that they want
to deal with right now but boy it's out
there i i guess i lied i have one last
one for you uh rick stroud interpret for
me and brady's farewell statement
when he mentioned bruce arians and he
mentioned driving bruce aryan's crazy
what
you want to interpret that one saying
that he's not going to drive but he's
crazy anymore what's that well i mean i
mean they did get antonio brown in here
right
that was
that was that was pretty crazy and i
know bruce didn't want any part of them
look uh tom was very demanding tom is
very demanding he got pretty much
everything he asked for but he asked for
a
lot
and
and and so i think you know whether it's
changing the offense
um changing the personnel
you know
uh i want this guy on the field i don't
want that guy on the field i mean that's
just that's sort of who who tom was and
that's why he's you know the greatest
winner of all time but he's not an easy
guy especially in his late you know his
late years when he had that you know he
had that power um and
i think bruce had to do a lot of bending
and he did and
i think he appreciated that and i think
he appreciated um you know that the
glazers gave him what he needed and and
uh it was a it was another way of doing
things
and you know and bruce was able to
accommodate him and i think that's what
that was all about i think he's just
you know the patients and and some of
the personnel moves that they had to
make that maybe bruce wouldn't have made
especially with guys like antonio that
he was talking about one last thing for
you rick as i let you go
suggesting a story for you or somebody
can look into this however you want to
look at it
when evans grabbed that ball out of the
air in the playoffs
and that touchdown the final touchdown
pass of brady's career over
jaylen ramsey he took the football and
he threw it in the stands
do you know did you see that
i did and i didn't know if anybody got
that one back i know number 600 was
worth a few things yeah
where is that football
where's the ball where is that ball rick
that's the one i want to know about
right now staring at it right now
retirement
rick stroud i'd like to announce my
retirement
yeah you're not going to drive aryans
crazy anymore all of that stuff right
there's a statement no they're not going
to thankfully they won't drive me crazy
i don't know but i i you know i'm
waiting for that
for that text message that goes have i
got a story for you that's right
no doubt no doubt rick thanks for the
time we'll chat uh as the uh
as the season moves along here thanks
for the call as always thanks man
that's rick stroud right here
that was funny i'm looking at it and if
right now
that would be amazing where is that
rick's shifter imitation that wasn't bad
rick rick caliendo
that was really good
frank stroud that was good that was good
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here